There's also so many fan remixes and remakes of your songs on YouTube.
I was wondering if you have a favorite there. I know there's Maria,...
...the young girl who I think really embodies a lot of what is interesting about technology.
Maria is just so special and you know she's like ten years old.
But even ten year olds today know how to work a webcam and upload a YouTube video, you know?
And I think that is why, for myself, my campaign and my album has been so successful...
...is because, I too, am a child of the dot-com era. Me and my father ran an Internet company...
...when I was really young, so I was listening to lots of technology...
...talk, jargon over the dinner table,...
...not understanding 'til much later what it all meant.
She's beautiful. She's very young and she has a voice in the world and she...
...latched onto a song that was very risky for me to put out so soon in my career.
But if I could just touch maybe ten...
...ten year olds in the world in every single continent, maybe I could make a difference.
Do we have the Maria video? I think it would be good for people to see it.
I think we may have it queued up.
She's just so amazing!
What I would like to speak about is the way that we experience music now.
We experience the music through the Internet but it has really great effects,...
...and it also has really negative effects. The great effect is Maria.
The negative effect is you sort of, quite mathematically input your songs and your soul into a computer,...
...and out spits out charts.
So the fan experience now, digitally, is they buy the song...
...and then they get into chat rooms and they watch the song climb a chart.
But somebody like Maria has no pretension. She's wildly innocent and beautiful...
...and she only cares about the music and the lyrics.
So what I'm working on doing now is creating a fan experience with the release of "Born This Way,"...
...that takes them a bit away from the computer in terms of the actual purchase of the song.
I want to encourage the fans to experience the music and the lyrics...
...removed of that sort of behind the computer banter.
When I was a kid, I was standing outside of HMV,...
...praying that I saw Billy Joe's fingernail in the window, wanted to get my Green Day CD signed.
I was hoping that I would see Thom Yorke when Radiohead came in.
You know, that is what I wanna recreate for my fans.
We've done it with the Monster Ball and now I wanna do it with album retail.